Donna is with us in Pennsylvania hey
Donna how are you hi I'm good how about
you
better than I deserve how can I help um
okay so I've listened to your show I've
heard you talk about the student loans
and parent responsibilities and forgive
me if I get upset I was stupid plain and
simple but I'm trying not to compound it
so I ended up with two sons and I came
out with a Parent PLUS loan of three
hundred and sixty nine thousand dollars
a boy a girl and now granted one is a
biomedical engineer one is a researcher
with NASA they landed well they're
making around 65 to 70 thousand okay so
it wasn't like they took anything but
still that was sounded like they should
maybe be making to watch that the first
couple years they got to put in there
okay their time you know was her ain't
was there any handshake agreement
between you and these rocket scientists
that they're going to repay in any of
this we talked about that I I'm a single
mom
their dad does not participate in any of
this or help or any way like that and I
said I will do this for you but were the
three musketeers here this is the three
of us in this together so they know that
they need to pay it back Oh same time
I'm the parent I'm the adult
I always happen what do you mind I make
around 85 okay well I I agree you're
you're not an unwilling victim you're a
grown lady you signed up for this mess
but it's a mess and it's going to
require a village so the yeah the three
musketeers are going to have to get
together and kill Sally an assassination
squad believe me if they would just let
us have a decent interest rate it's the
interest rate in the compound interest
well not really
because really pretend let's pretend for
a second and I sure hope I'm not
pretending but let's pretend for a
second we had three people making
$100,000 a year which is where we are 24
to 36 months from today mm-hmm that's
$300,000 income to deal with a you said
369,000 debt that's what you said right
okay so if each of you chip in live on
you know make a hundred and live on 50
I'm just using a round number that's a
hundred and fifty a year on this that's
two and a half years right and that
leads to my question I sold my house
recently not for the student loan debt
it was a four-bedroom that I just might
kids or in other states right now so I
paid off all of my debt and this isn't
right but I paid off the other there's
no credit cards there's that for except
applause all right okay so I have forty
thousand left it goes on this I'm trying
to figure and that's what my questions
like should I leave this in a nest egg
for my cell no four okay we have to
attack the student loan that all three
of you have to pretend like you are one
household and you are going to live like
three college students broke people
nothing no life and you're going to
destroy this mess because your other
option is to try to do this some point
gradually or quote-unquote more
reasonably and you will never get out
okay this is too big it's too
breathtaking it's my stomach's in my
throat and it's not even my debt believe
me every night it's like I don't know
what to do yeah I know what to do you
get on the phone with the other two
Musketeers and let's form a strategy for
assassinating Sallie Mae I mean we are
gonna say you're putting in fifty
everybody's putting in four thousand
dollars a month that's 48 thousand
dollars a year all three of us are gonna
do that or more because I
you know I didn't sign up to commit
financial suicide for two rocket
scientists and that's where I didn't
understand whether or not I should split
my money between the student loan debt
and keeping something the problem is
it's in your name and if these two guys
decided they're gonna be goop's
instead of three musketeers you're
really up a creek okay so I'm sure
hoping they're not goop's I'm sure
hoping there were men that will follow
through and keep their word and take
care of their momma now if they are the
best okay
then let's play while we still have that
camaraderie let's get agreement that
let's start putting some actual numbers
and all three of us are saying hey you
know it's a permission to play I gotta
ante up and ante up everybody's gonna
ante up four grand a month okay and
you're gonna work extra jobs until your
income makes it easier to do four grand
a month because four grand a month this
forty-eight thousand times three is a
hundred and fifty thousand into three
sixty nine gets us out of debt in two
and a half to three years well it's it's
simple math did you do I mean divide 369
by fifty thousand it's like when I was
doing the math here I'm like I'm looking
at seven to ten years yeah well you're
looking at you doing by yourself - and I
am assigning the other two members of
the Three Musketeers to assist in Sallie
Mae's assassination this has to occur we
have one for all all for one baby you're
gonna have to start sending all count of
three musketeer memes back and forth and
cartoons and have some fun with this
Sallie Mae is going down moms and dads
do not repeat Donna's life
you don't want Donna's life don't do
what Donna did